carlos is with us in san jose california
hi carlos how are you okay good great
thank you for taking my call um
we had a quick question so our family is
on step number two uh we found you a
few months ago we have about 75 000
dollars in debt
which uh 62 of that is student debt our
income is about 150
000. good you're going to be done faster
earlier this year
earlier this year we were able to buy
our first home but we used a down
payment assistant program
so this is a zero percent interest for
30 years
but they do take a share of appreciation
which is uh 17
which is what they lent us the question
to you is should we focus on
paying down that debt the student debt
or
trying to knock out the 100 000 dollars
we owe for uh
that down payment assistance program
well hold on carlos what's the other 13
000 if 62 000 of it is student loan debt
he said you had 75 what's the other 13
uh it's about 12 and a half in
a loan i mean a car loan okay
all right well
the shared appreciation mortgage is not
a good deal for you
uh the longer you stay in it the harder
it's going to be for you to get out of
it
because the government now owns 17 of
your house
that's what this amounts to um
so uh i you know paying the 100 000
off does not get rid of that refinancing
the loan
and getting the whole loan gone gets rid
of it
so probably what i'm going to do is work
to get rid of the car debt then the
student loan
and then i'm going to refinance and get
out of this sap loan the shared
appreciation loan
uh the sap and so um
it's uh um yeah
uh yeah you just
the the idea that they're gonna get 17
of your growth
because they loaned you money um i mean
i haven't seen one of those in
years i didn't know they were still
doing them yeah i'd heard of the rural
housing where they have the recapture
but that's the subject of that yeah but
i just heard about the sap
i mean we used to do them back when
rates were ridiculous
like when raids were 14 and 15 we i i
mean shared appreciation loans started
popping up then because people were
doing anything they could to get an
interest rate down
um but in this current world why in the
world
would they even have a product like that
out there and carlos it's not a good
deal for you
you did not save enough on your interest
rate uh in order to
justify giving up 17 of your ownership
so i'm gonna work my way through the
good news is you make 150 you can pay
off the 75 in two years when that's done
let's talk about refinancing this house
and getting rid of the sap
yeah and getting the house into your
name completely and ending whatever
whatever penalties this results in and
everything else get it all repaid with a
stupid refinance and
let's get it straightened out that way
so hey man thanks for the call
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five so here's the thing
there's no shortcut to any places worth
going
there's no shortcut to building wealth
a shortcut to home ownership is going to
get you a bit on the butt yeah
oh yeah a shortcut if it sounds too good
to be true it's because it is
it you know it's um easy
payments always means
dumb butt idea you mean 90 days
isn't the same as cash dave that means
it's the truth it's not the same as
not and so i mean when something feels
easy
and painful i mean not no pain involved
in you actually saving up and paying for
it
you're about to get your butt bit that's
what's happening